[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 18 février bien de
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 78 tout
de suite les titres de cette édition
plus de six cent trente mille visiteurs
pour l'édition 2019 le salon de
l'agriculture au sepanso 22 février
prochain à paris expo porte de
versailles
un rendez vous au département des
yvelines élu de france seront
représentés la campagne pour le premier
tour du scrutin des élections
municipales continue nous ferons le
point sur de nouveaux enjeux est de
nouveau candidat à saint quentin en
yvelines et du théâtre de la musique et
du patrimoine trop journaliste culture
vous donnera plusieurs rendez vous à ne
pas manquer pour les jours à venir
lyon débute avec cette information une
année 2010 9 encore marquée par
l'augmentation dès violences sexuelles
tout comme les escroqueries le ministère
de l'intérieur a communiqué les chiffres
de l'insécurité la dé la délinquance
pour l'année 2019
plus précisément dans les yvelines vous
le voyez sont en augmentation les
tentatives d'homicides les vols de
véhicules ou encore les viols par
rapport à l'est à l'année 2018 à
l'inversé cambriolages ou les
infractions à la législation sur les
stupéfiants sont en baisse
[Musique]
du 22 février au 1er mars et le grand
rendez vous annuel de l'agriculture
paris expo porte de versailles accueille
la nouvelle édition du salon
international de l'agriculture
neuf jours pendant lesquels les yvelines
et l'île de france sont représentées
notamment grâce à nos invités bonsoir à
tous les deux alors jean claude guénin
que vous êtes le premier vice président
d'île de france terre de saveurs
anciennement le cervia olivier vous êtes
responsable commercial de la firme de la
tramblais située à la boissière école
je vais commencer d'abord avec vous
monsieur guennec j'imagine que c'est un
rendez vous important pour l'île de
france
le salon bien sûr c'est un rendez vous
important c'est pour mettre en valeur
toute la production agricole
francilienne passion on pense qu'elles
que des maisons que des constructions
que des routes des autoroutes mais il ya
une agriculture relativement important
qui représente pratiquement 50% du
territoire francilien
c'est à dire que le public quand il
vient vous voir il étonné parce que vous
leur apprenez il est très étonné qu'ils
aient une agriculture performante et de
vatry ce dans tous les secteurs
d'activité parce qu'on a vraiment du blé
à l'élevage mais aussi aux légumes aux
fruits à l'article tueur à la pépinière
on a vraiment le mien est vraiment toute
une palette qu'on a envie de le france
qu'on peut retrouver dans son assiette
qui est aussi le fromage
olivier vous êtes présent plutôt au
salon du fromage et des produits
laitiers qui se tient jusqu'au 26
février
mais au même endroit la ferme de la
tramblais y assistent à chaque édition
que c'est tous les deux ans oui tous les
deux ans nous sommes présents au salon
des fromages et nous présentons nos nos
fromages avec cette année une vraie
innovation puisque on passe en
agriculture biologique
voilà après deux ans de conversion c'est
un beau passage avec la création de
nouveaux fromages et également d'une
gamme de yaourts biologique
on va en parler un peu plus tard et
jean-claude guennec c'est l'occasion
aussi de rencontrer peut-être des
nouveaux producteurs ou de d'inciter des
jeunes à s'installer qui hésiteraient
aujourd'hui bon je pense pense pas
forcément le lieu
surtout de la communication grand public
aisé montrer ce qu'on sait faire bien
sûr on reçoit gérait la population mais
aussi le milieu politique toutes
tendances confondues
nos fournisseurs l'a très vite y
d'attractivité aussi permet aussi de
faire venir éventuellement des
restaurateurs il ya tout un ensemble de
choses
c'est quand même un salon où on
communique sur les productions qui sont
faites en ile-de-france depuis quelques
années l'agriculture est touché par une
vague d'agri bashing lancer un mouvement
de méfiance envers le monde agricole est
ce qu'un salon tel que celui ci ça
permet aussi de rassurer le consommateur
effectivement pour pour nous ça permet
de rassurer le consommateur
nous nous travaillons selon des méthodes
en agroécologie aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qui nous permet de
respecter les sols on s'occupe du
bien-être animal évidemment mais
également du bien être des hommes
donc tout ça ça remet en valeur et on va
dire en bon on va dire en valeur notre
notre un autre type d'agriculture notre
mode de production et tout ça à deux pas
de paris puisque on est à moins de 60 km
de paris habilitée de la triumph et on
fait tout de a à z c'est à dire qu'on
produit l'alimentation pour nos animaux
ont produit le lait avec nos animaux
donc des vaches des chèvres
on transforme ce lait directement à la
ferme et on va même jusqu à retraiter
les déchets issus de l'élevage et de la
fromagerie donc les les fumiers et le
lactosérum donc le petit lait et on
retravaille ça à travers un méthaniseur
agricoles pour produire de l'électricité
et de l'énergie
voilà donc ça c'est important on va
vraiment au bout de cette démarche
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'épandage de digestat
donc un fertilisant naturel issu de la
méthanisation
jacques le guen est la région ile de
france vous l'avez dit appelant de
producteurs c'est l'occasion de
promouvoir le circuit court aussi j'aime
bien manger local tout appel mais avant
nous réduire aussi au revoir moi je suis
maraîchers et acima
donc je connais dans les yvelines pas
loin d'ici juin circuits courts
antitabac bâtisse et de lacérer et
d'expliquer ce que l'on fait pas
seulement des ricol on a toujours
tendance à pas expliquer nos méthodes et
parce qu'on a peur et c'est à nous de
communiquer envers le public
c'est un nom qui travaillent s'ouvrir
encore aujourd'hui en salles il faut
communiquer communiquer expliquer ce
qu'on fait parce que vraiment on a une
culture de plus en plus propres à vous
de mentionner tout à l'heure c'est aussi
un rendez-vous les responsables
politiques se déplacent souvent en
nombre un moyen de sensibiliser aussi à
la situation des agriculteurs qu'on
connaît qui est pas toujours très rose
tous les jours mais on sensibilise
systématiquement tous les délits
politiques qui passe où les
personnalités qui représente un secteur
d'activité justement pour communiquer
surgir et tous les métiers de la filière
agricole pour nous aussi on a
régulièrement des visites justement de
deux politiques ceux sur la fin pour
montrer notre type de production est
responsable et donc ça c'est extrêmement
important
est-ce que vous profitent pour échanger
d'autres professionnels aussi bien sûr
bien sûr et les professionnels nous on
échange beaucoup sur sur des pratiques
ont fait partie d'associations
d'éleveurs de producteurs fromagers et
de producteurs fermiers
parce que notre particularité est
vraiment d'être fermiers alors avant de
continuer avec vous en parlons notamment
de vos activités au sein d'île de france
terre de saveurs et de la ferme de
tremblay je vous propose qu'on parte
cette fois à son chant christophe robin
est agriculteur à la ferme de une fière
et participera au salon de l'agriculture
avec le mouvement à grille demain c'est
le premier mouvement rassemblant les
principales organisations
professionnelles du secteur agricole
autour d'une vision commune de
l'agriculture
manon varaldo a rencontré cet éleveur de
volailles regarder
christophe robin est agriculteur depuis
2012 à la ferme de la une hier suite au
départ en retraite de ses parents en
il prend les rênes de cette exploitation
c'est un éleveur
passionné j'ai pris l'habitude de
prévenir les volailles quand même quand
on arrive dans le bâtiment c'est éviter
de le stress aussi à la ferme de la
hunière des poulets fermiers sont
produits dans ce bâtiment d'élevage 600
volailles sont présentes dans ce 80
mètres carrés
on a tout réorganiser l'espace et
l'ensemble des bâtiments donc la
prochaine étape ça va être de mettre une
porte dans le fond ici dans l'opinion
qui sera automatisé dans son
exploitation à son chant christophe
robin fabrique l'aliment des volailles
avec les céréales de la ferme et on
cultivateurs jeu produit à la fois du
blé et du maïs que c'est la base de
l'aliment des volailles cet agriculteur
prend soin de ses volailles qui sont
bien en chair alors les amis ça va là
dedans avec une durée d'élevage entre 90
et 120 joueurs la semaine prochaine je
vais emmener un petit peu au salon de
l'agriculture pour fournir le stand
hagrid map époque vivent là on avait dû
3 kg + 3 kg en vivre christophe robin
fait partie de ce mouvement qui
rassemble plusieurs exploitants afin de
lutter notamment contre la grille
bashing une certaine méfiance à l'égard
du monde agricole
il va falloir continuer à nourrir une
population qui est grandissante
satisfaire les besoins
bien-être animal et en production de
qualité et de proximité il faut réussir
à faire revenir les gens à la ferme
qu'ils aient qu'ils aient en visu ce
qu'on fait pour avoir un lien avec ses
consommateurs l'agriculteur se rend au
marché de clairefontaine en yvelines
christophe et damien met en place les
produits de la ferme de la lumière c'est
8 90 le prix foy sont jetés c'est la
plaquette
si tu as un but sur quoi que ce soit eu
pour l'applicateur l'éleveur maîtrise
90% de la production de la filière
seules les parties abattage et des
coupes sont délégués les consommateurs
ont pu déguster les produits de la ferme
et parfois repartir avec c'est le nom
que vous voulez christophe robin sera
présent mercredi 26 février sur le stand
à grille demain du salon de
l'agriculture s'est produit aussi allée
bon dimanche on retrouve nos invités
jean claude guennec vice président d'île
de france terre de saveurs et olivier
weill responsable commercial de la ferme
de la tramblais jean claude guénin que
vous le disiez l'ile-de-france ses 49%
terres agricoles agricole près de
cinquante mille exploitations agricoles
ils s'invitent cinq mille 5000
j'ai mis à zéro en plus la structure ile
de france terre de saveurs ça permet de
faire connaître ce patrimoine versées
par son patrimoine mais faudrait aussi
savoir que le tiers de saveurs ya pas
que les agriculteurs il ya toute la
filière
c'est d'ailleurs on a besoin des
artisans les ligues danger ils sont avec
tout sur le stand on a besoin des
bouchons d'amour besoin pour les
fromages
l'artisan boulanger et bien sûr on a les
politiques qui sont autour avec vous
c'est à dire il ya vraiment tout la
tuillière ça va aussi bien du chocolat
qu'à l'huile de colza de la moutarde
mais tous les produits qui sont issus
tous qui nous nourrit voilà et qui
viennent principalement de l'île de
france donc on va vraiment aussi même
dans les restaurants il a vraiment toute
la filière pour valoriser soleil est une
marque qui était mise en place produit
en ile de france créé par le conseil
régional avec un logo bien distinctif
plus de 1400 produit déjà référencés
vous cherchez à aller encore plus haut
déjà faut bien sûr mais des produits ils
sont à un moment donné il ya une limite
mais le produit c'est de faire connaître
produit en ile de france laisse tant pis
voilà ça va aussi par exemple et de
gourmands qui sont entrés pierre il faut
des gâteaux ils ont l'estampillé jurait
produit en ile de france et c'est ça
qu'il faut communiquer on est capable de
produire des produits à proximité et la
marque a été créée pour cette raison là
pour toute la filière bon que du champ à
l'assiette on arrive à reconnaître aussi
bien dans un restaurant qui est dans un
étal de marché ou que dans la
distribution au sens large ont pu se
reconnaître les produits qui sont
produits à côté de paris est votre rôle
aussi c'est un accompagnement une
expertise pour les professionnels quand
ils ont besoin des nains conseil
non on n'est pas cette voie parce que la
communication s'est énormément un budget
faut savoir c'est principalement la
région qui est le financeur et après il
ya des financements complémentaires mais
c'est la région qui finance à 90% terre
de saveurs
l'idée c'est de manger franciliens donc
si je comprends bien est ce qu'un jour
on pourrait ou c'est peut-être déjà le
cas les fromages de la ferme de tremblay
soit dans les lycées par exemple
bien sûr c'est le doute mais après c'est
tellement exponentielle il faut bien
cadré fois avant c'est donc bien sûr
c'est la volonté première mais bon tout
paris sait porter un jour et on va pas
faire en un jour il ya du travail qui
est fait parce qu'on a laissé
l'agriculture pendant sa tombe de temps
à la traîne et là on revient mais pour
remettre en production c'est évidemment
compliqué ça faisait ça se fait pas
comme ça en claquant des doigts c'est
justement ça
la ferme peut être intéressé de fournir
comme ça des établissements peut-être
dans département d'abord avant de
s'ouvrir plus largement à l'île de
france c'est déjà ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui à travers certains de nos
clients grossistes qui fournissent des
établissements scolaires qui fournissent
des des restaurants d'entreprise voilà
donc on travaille déjà sur sur ce
système là il ya une demande qui est de
plus en plus grande de consommer local
donc ça c'est important la demande de
consommer bio est également là donc nous
rassemble c'est c2c ces deux sujets là
et aujourd'hui on intéresse beaucoup de
beaucoup de distributeurs pour pour ces
raisons au niveau des justement pour
fournir les lycées ça se passera par
département ce que chaque département
aussi sa spécificité
est-ce que de france terre de saveurs
fait par rapport aux spécificités de
chaque département
non nous on est là simplement pour
mettre relation à compagnie voilà parce
que le problème c'est le transport c'est
le dernier kilomètre que ce soit dans
nos départements nos paris c'est là que
le travail doit être faible et c'est pas
la terre de saveurs qui fait ça nous on
met en relation ont créé les outils et
on essaye de faire avancer et de
développer et surtout que les gens
puissent aussi se rencontrer appartement
vous avez tout le monde toute la filière
qui est autour de la table c'est quand
même plus facile d'avancer ensemble
vous devez veiller au niveau de la ferme
de latran blessé depuis 1967 et j'ai cru
comprendre plus inspiré beaucoup du
territoire sur lequel vous êtes
notamment cette forêt de rambouillet qui
est tout proche que de fait en cela on
s'inspire de ce qui se passe dans la
forêt c'est à dire que aujourd'hui on à
transposer le modèle de la forêt qui n'a
besoin de rien pour pour vivre
donc on la transporte on l'a transposé
sur sur la partie agricole
donc depuis 2008 on laboure plus nos
terres on travaille uniquement sur
couvert végétal en semis direct ce qui
nous permet d'avoir un sol couverts en
permanence et de produire différents
types de céréales de deux d'aliments
pour pour nos animaux et malheureusement
on n'a pas assez de terres pour pour
alimenter nos animaux donc on a fait
appel à des partenaires qui sont à moins
de 100 km de chez nous et qui respecte
notre cahier des charges également qui
aujourd'hui sont en conversion bio et
qui vont arriver à la certification
également en même temps que nous pour
pour pouvoir alimenter nos animaux voilà
donc aujourd'hui sur notre territoire
on va transformer à peu près mille
hectares de terres en bio donc sur notre
initiative et pour qu'on m'aide à passer
au bio justement c'est une demande des
consommateurs s'était alors une volonté
de la faire il ya une demande des
consommateurs effectivement nous on a on
a pris le parti depuis 2008 de
travailler plutôt sur la partie
agroécologie donc d'aller un tout petit
peu plus loin que que le label bio par
contre aujourd'hui le seul label qui est
reconnu par le grand public
ces labels bio donc c'est une première
étape avant d'aller plus loin
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur ce
plateau je le rappelle jean claude
guénin que vous êtes de l'île de france
terre de saveurs
cette structure sera présente au salon
de l'agriculture qui se tient du 22
février au 1er mars à porte de
versailles
olive éveiller la ferme de la tramblais
sera l exposantes lors du salon du
fromage et des produits laitiers c'est
du 23 au 26 février
mais c'est au même endroit
[Musique]
en 2020 le conseil municipal des enfants
de guyancourt fête ses 30 ans pour
l'occasion la ville recherche les
anciens membres qu'ils ont composée
depuis sa création en 1990
ce conseil est composé d'élèves
scolarisés du ce2 à la sixième de
participer à la vie de la commune la
célébration de l'anniversaire est prévue
pour l'automne prochain un point
maintenant sur la campagne des
municipales stéphane jamain aux
clayes-sous-bois et tête de liste
d'énergie positive c'est une liste sans
étiquette qui souhaite mettre en avant
l'écologie la justice sociale et la
participation citoyenne
manon varaldo s'est rendu à l'une de ses
réunions les siennes depuis plus de 30
ans stéphanie jamin et tête de liste
d'énergie positive qui rassemble une
diversité de citoyens lors des réunions
la participation citoyenne et l'écoutent
sont mises en avant
une liste qui n'est pas soutenu par un
parti politique
vous avez eu l'occasion de partir à
d'autres réunions des trois autres
listes et la houle s'est différencié
c'est qu'on avait le droit aux
désaccords
stéphanie jamin souhaite une démocratie
locale plus transparente avec par
exemple 9 conseils municipaux par an au
lieu de cinq
le but instaurer un temps d'échangé
entre les cliniciens et les élus en
début de conseil
c'est quelque chose de vraiment nouveau
je trouve ça on est en train de
construire dont on construit pas dans la
politique on construit un peu entre amis
mais pour une ville pour tous
la proximité une des valeurs de cette
liste stéphanie jamin et les
participants préparent leur planning
d'actions
oui mais ça se prépare comme alain leur
objectif aller à la rencontre des clés
siens du porte à porte a pour plusieurs
groupes pour aller présenter notre
programme et la première proposition
entre les siens nous avons également
prévu de
lisez les balades chrétienne qui se
déroule généralement sur des moments de
tant de villes etc les siens nous allons
à la rencontre
nous allons
l'or aussi voir exposées dans nos
propositions mais vraiment écouter quels
sont leurs besoins
nous avons prévu des distribution dans
les boîtes aux lettres de manière
classique
une réunion publique est organisée à 10h
le samedi 29 février à l'école on répond
des clayes-sous-bois pour cette page
municipal 2020 focus aujourd'hui sur les
enjeux du scrutin à plaisir la commune a
rejoint l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines en 2016 une ville à l'entrée
à la campagne yvelinoise développement
durable urbanisation désert médical le
détail des enjeux de michael et demi
d'euros et de nicolas landry c'est une
commune ouverte sur la plaine de
versailles un territoire partagé entre
la campagne et la ville plaisir et ses
trente et un mille habitants rejoint la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en 2016 ce
territoire essaie de trouver un
équilibre entre urbanisation et zones
naturelles
le pôle commercial va s'agrandir cette
année avec l'ouverture d'open sky et des
emplois pour le plaisir oies à la clé
d'urbanisation c'est la réhabilitation
du centre bourg et la rénovation du
quartier du vélib ou un investissement
de 65 millions d'euros un projet déjà
engagé que devra poursuivre le prochain
maire de la ville avec une prise en
compte plus globale de ce quartier
touché par la délinquance les questions
sociales et l'emploi des aménagements
environnementaux sont aussi prévues dans
ce futur écoquartier l'environnement est
aussi une préoccupation plaisir compte
une forêt plusieurs parcs naturels
la question des transports et de la
circulation sera posée notamment après
l'aménagement de la rd 30 et de la
passerelle plaisir et l'encours le
phénomène de désert médical plane au
dessus de plaisir une ville classée en
zone d'action complémentaire par l'
agence régionale de santé
ils sont quatre médecins pour 10000
habitants 2017 selon les derniers
chiffres de l'ue rps il y avait quatorze
médecins généralistes ils sont âgés de
50 ans en moyenne et dans le cadre de
cette campagne des municipales tv 78 en
association avec radio sensations vous
propose des débats entre les candidats
ce mardi soir émission consacrée à
trappes c'est à retrouver à chaque fois
à 20h sur tv 78 et sur la fréquence 98.4
pour sensation yvelines et leur plaît le
replay sur tv 78 points comme un lot de
culture à présent
[Musique]
depuis le début du mois le domaine de
dampierre change de visage la propriété
est en train de se parer d'un
échafaudage deux ans de travaux sont
ainsi lancés principalement sur le logis
c'est la partie centrale du château vont
être rénovés les charpentes les lucarnes
ou encore les menuiseries des précisions
de pascal thévard directeur général du
domaine au micro de marylène et la
piscine où nous allons pas celle
échafaudages il faut évidemment protéger
la couverture qui va être enlevée donc
du coup il ya un toit qui va être mis
sur cet échafaudage et on va poser une
bâche tout autour du château puisque
nous avons eu la chance au mois de
septembre de trouver dans les greniers
et bien des gravures anciennes des
façades du château de la fin du xviie
siècle et c'est ces éléments là que nous
allons mettre à l'échelle sur le
l'échafaudage les équipes du château
proposeront pendant l'été des visites
inédites un guide conférencier
présentera les travaux d'un point de vue
historique au public est avec nous en
plateau maintenant aurélie rond journée
cette culture est élevé 78 bonsoir
mélanie alors dans quelques minutes on
vous retrouve pour le cetud culture
votre magazine mais est ce qu'on a le
droit à un petit avant goût
alors oui nous irons notamment à
guyancourt plus précisément à la ferme
de bel ébat qui proposera une nouvelle
création au public ce sera les 25 et 26
février parce qu'elles ont tonini adapte
sur scène la pièce d'edward hopper
chluski toile d'araignée alors
l'histoire se déroule en pleine
dictature argentine dans les années 70
une pièce très engagé comme vous le
verrez on parlera musique également plus
particulièrement de jazz puisque la 22e
édition du festival jazz à toute heure
débute le 28 février en vallée de
chevreuse
au programme à cinq week-ends de concert
une quinzaine d'artistes neuf villes
différentes
une manifestation qui a su évoluer au
fil des années et puis on ne présente
plus la compagnie déclic théâtre le 25
février
les comédiens présenteront leurs
dernières créations à la merise attrape
et conte noir nous emmène en 2035 ou si
âmes égarées intègre un programme de
désintoxication à des écrans un sujet
très actuel
merci aurélie est justement ce sujet
très actuel comme vous le dites sur
le nouveau spectacle de la compagnie
déclic théâtre je vous propose qu'on le
regarde aller réalisation c'est vous et
si dans quelques années notre monde
hyperconnecté était totalement dépendant
des écrans pour sa nouvelle création
écran noir la compagnie déclic théâtre
met en scène une dystopie qui se déroule
en 2035 la surconsommation technologique
et la raréfaction des ressources
énergétiques qu'on traîne la société a
changé ses habitudes
cette pièce nous permet de suivre le
parcours de 6 âmes égarées accro aux
écrans il ya une de ces personnes qui va
être recruté par cette communauté
étrange en tout cas qui s'appelle screen
l'ess qui propose de désintoxiquer les
gens des écrans et cette personne va
animer ce village addiction aux réseaux
sociaux harcèlement numérique plusieurs
thèmes autour de l'impact des écrans
dans nos vies sont abordés au cours de
la pièce un travail de création qui
s'est fait avec des artistes associés la
compagnie trappistes a notamment fait
appel au metteur en scène laurent mazet
il viendrait mais on est il a eu il est
venu souvent travaillé avec déclic
théâtre et on a des valeurs communes sur
le théâtre citoyen sur sur le théâtre
comme vecteur d'émancipation et de
réflexion de notre monde
en résidence à la mise la compagnie
peaufine les derniers détails lors des
répétitions certains textes sont réécrit
avec les comédiens on aborde en fait si
point de vue qu'on pourrait avoir sur le
rapport aux écrans et l'idée de délivrer
un message c'est justement de poser des
questions une satire drôle noir acide et
d'actualité qui fait réfléchir sur
l'omniprésence des écrans dans notre
société c'est la fin de ce journal
une édition que vous pouvez revoir en
replay sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme sur notre application
merci de nous avoir suivis belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]